hallo guten tag ich werde bestimmt nicht
ich in der tat obwohl ich tatsächlich
wirklich ein bisschen gezockt habe na ja
also ich habe bisher glaube ich einmal
den sieg geholt
aus 50 gespielten kunden direkt hier
freunde gefunden der lobby ich verfolge
neuerdings übrigens eine etwas andere
taktik bei ford und zwar gehe ich immer
zu tötet hours weil die action und alle
raus meine damen und herren jetzt
fliegen wir mal eben zu töten teilte
towers ist für alle die vorteile nicht
so oft spielen so dass wo am meisten los
ist also das ist diese stadt die mit den
ganzen hochhäuser und da vorne bei big
band ist die kiste drin und so und das
hier nennt sich jeder hier sind gar
keine sachen wtf mal schauen ob hier
noch irgendwer landet ich glaube
allerdings nicht so das heißt wegen
jetzt mal die etage runterschauen ob
hier ein paar menschen sind nahe hier
ist auch niemand allerdings sind hier
auch keine items mehr irgendwo hier ganz
nah sein schlüssel ich frage mich wo die
ganzen leute sind normalerweise ist
arena hier mal komplett überfüllt also
ok naja bush indem ich mich noch ein
bisschen munition raushaben corning was
ich brauche auf jeden fall nennt geht
hat da gerade von gesprochen hier oder
so glaube ich um sind hier unten
irgendwelche leute hier sogar noch eine
kiste mg tf beste was ist denn los hier
raketenwerfern
also hier noch ein bisschen munition
rausnehmen freunde verbände brauchen wir
nicht aber ich gehe mal eben ganz kurz
nach oben und trinken kurz den trank den
mikro kann dazu nein nein nein jetzt ist
der mensch fühle mich jetzt boxen oder
was okay ich dachte er ist okay der wird
es mit mir tanzen oder irgendwie so er
mir tatsächlich meinen ganzen schulze
stört also fragt mich grad schon so ein
bisschen ab aber gut freuen wir haben
240 raketenwerfer ist ein ganz ok staat
ich hätte gerade ganz ganz gern einen
schutz trank freunde aber gut nehmen wir
hier vorne mal die munition mit hier ist
wirklich kein mensch mehr okay krass a
ha ha ha ha was haben wir denn hier lobt
blog blog blog schild trank getrunken
hier können wir noch ein bisschen
paletten mitnehmen die geben glaube ich
immer am meisten holz ich habe ein paar
videos mal sofort nicht angeguckt als so
summa summarum look zeigen da oben wird
ihnen was gebaut ich weiß aber nicht ob
da hinten gerade leute sind ich bin auch
außerhalb der zone sehe ich gerade das
heißt die zone geht gar nicht mehr durch
täters hierdurch glaube jetzt mal eben
schnell einfach darüber ich habe nur ein
bisschen schiss dass mich jetzt
irgendwie einer gewechselt weil das hier
auch ab und zu mal vorkommen kann
mal schauen ob hier irgendwo leute sind
da es niemand mehr hier unten auch nicht
hält was ist denn hier los dieser sonst
sieht man viel geht hier vielmehr ab
meine ich habe mich als sonst mal mehr
auf den unterhaltungswert
die konzentriert als ich hier fordert
hochgeladen habe und geschaut dass ich
irgendwie vernünftig das ganze
kommentiere aber jetzt derzeit also
nicht seitdem ist ein bisschen herzog
ist mir das auch ein bisschen ernster
geworden hier ich höre schüsse aber ich
weiß nicht von wo die kommen also ich
kann das gerade echt nicht einschätzen
weil ich spiele auch ohne kopfhörer weil
ich habe keinen bock mit kopfhörern zu
sitzen im video hat er sich da jetzt
verschanzt oder was die sache ist dass
da vorne gleich der sturm hin wandert in
zwei minuten ist er da ich will aber
davor eigentlich noch diesen typen da
hinten holen
ich weiß allerdings nicht ob der da
vorne überhaupt noch ist weil da würde
doch da hinten da hinten ist auf jeden
fall ein typ ich weiß nicht ob ich das
machen sollte was ich jetzt gerade mache
aber ich versuche mich mal rüber zu
bauen zudem irgendwie und über den
drüber zu kommen
irgendein typ hallo hallo hallo hier ist
einfach niemand
doch gerade noch da
oh mein gott oh mein gott ich musste
halt jetzt vor laufen weil die zone von
hinten kam aber das ist ja auf dem berg
schildert jetzt auch nicht gedacht ich
hab mich gefragt wo die ganzen leute
sind aber die sind alle hier schon also
die die fliegen alle schon dahin alter
ich bin voll spät dran also macht für
mich wirklich gerade 0 sind irgendwie in
die arena zu gehen das heißt nicht mehr
jetzt irgendwie die mg genau hier vorne
mal schauen ob wir jetzt noch
irgendwelche leute gleich kommen die das
ding war eben auch machen wenn natürlich
geil wenn ich jetzt irgend eine shotgun
hätte oder so aber ja komm schilder camp
und warte auf mich mit einer shotgun
alles klar
[Musik]
ab geht's neue runde freunde ich bin
diesmal nicht bei kälte draußen
gesprungen weil wir das doch ein
bisschen zu ekelhaft gerade war dass
dieser typ der gewartet hat deswegen
gelte hier täglich riedroder so ist das
hier bietet in klein also ja keine
ahnung genau hier vorne liegt eigentlich
immer eine waffe genau deswegen gehe ich
jetzt mal hierhin genau haben wir die
hier vorne dass beides hier vorne haben
wir was ist das ein lagerfeuer oder so
hier in dem truck und hat dem tor sind
meistens noch eine kiste
das ist ja gar nur 50 prozentigen chance
die da auftritt das heißt wir haben ja
wir haben die kiste freuen und was
einmal darin bitte maschinengewehr genau
da hast du ich dachte erst auf dem
gebäude oben das wären wieder eine
dingens gewesene dieser eine waffe oder
so deswegen dachte ich okay da geh ich
sondern die wir jetzt nicht in welcher
tiefe springt jetzt ist keine kiste
deswegen wollte ich halt nicht zu diesen
typen weil ich dachte okay der hat jetzt
eine ganz schön große waffe oder
irgendwie so aber gut wenn da jetzt
irgend so ein sprung falle war das ist
natürlich blöd gelaufen
mal schauen wo hier hinten paar leute
sind da hinten ist niemand hier vorne
auch nicht ob ich bin auch hart aufs
hohe ross ganz geil wäre jetzt halt ein
besseres maschinengewehr also ich schaue
mir noch nie vorne eben in dem gebäude
nach hier erstmal positions- kiste genau
nehmen wir das erstmal schön mit genau
hier vorne die raketen auch brauchen
mein gott wo bist du warst du kannst du
dir näher
ich brauche schnell eine schrotflinte
ich habe mal wieder hier zählte towers
anvisiert aber ich jetzt für die runde
nochmal ein bisschen action haben wollte
freunde habt ihr eigentlich brauche
darauf das hab ich mir überlegt weil ich
das noch nicht so richtig glaube ich auf
youtube gefunden habe aber vielleicht
bin ich einfach auf den falschen kanälen
unterwegs so ein bisschen fortnight
challenges zu machen also ok in die
arena kann ich nicht mehr also so ein
bisschen so was wie beispielsweise ok
eine komplette runde überleben nur mit
was haben wir hier okay hier ist oh mein
gott keine lieder eine shotgun das heißt
mal schauen wo der titel jetzt her kommt
auch junge das war nicht mehr und so
war's da springt er genau in dem moment
runter alter ich wollte euch neben den
genen und die mehrheit geben aber gut
das hat jetzt nicht so ganz geklappt
haben wir noch irgendwas hier ist eine
kiste auf jeden fall bitte im gkv
gewöhnliches können hier vielleicht per
leiter kamen dankeschön aber ums thema
zurückzukommen ich hätte auf jeden fall
bocken partner challenges zu machen so
dass sie beispielsweise eine komplette
runde überleben nur ohne waffen
so verstehe was meine wer halt auch
entspannt wenn hier mal irgend ein paar
leute kommen würden
sehr schön danke dafür so hier mal eben
kurz dem mauerbau und sicher ist sicher
freunde jetzt mal eben kurz die
trinkerei sie damit wir uns ein bisschen
so ein schild hier unten aufbauen ihr
seht schon 25 55 und jetzt muss ich mir
eben kurz hier organisieren die
schatzkammer dahin dass hier hin genauso
so genau
jetzt können wir vorne auch wieder raus
zack zack zwei hierdurch öffnen und
jetzt wird rasiert ich verstand mich
jetzt mal einfach kurz ein bisschen
gehen wir mal wieder eine etage höher
irgendeiner schießt auf mich aber ich
weiß auch nicht von wo hinten ist auf
jeden fall niemand da unten da hinten
baut jemand keine ahnung da hinten ist
auch niemand wo sind kann ich wo sind
die schüsse freunde ich habe jetzt hat
auch keinen bock irgendwo draußen herum
zu laufen und frei über die straße
irgendwie zu laufen weil ich habe jetzt
auch keine so so krassen waffen aber ich
meinte irgendwo müssen doch das war
davor noch nicht gebaut glaube ich habe
oben baut gerade auf jeden fall einer
das heißt ich glaube ich gehe mal zudem
hoch man schon ein bisschen action
action acom her
you may use tear sprachchat bin ich dann
komplett bescheuert
[Musik]
hier geht's wieder ordentlich ab mit den
dance moves in der lobby ich frage mich
halt ohne spaß immer wieder jede runde
aufs neue wie leute vor mir da jetzt
irgendwie sein können weil ich springe
eigentlich perfekt raus war er geht
dahin ja cool wo gehe ich dann hin
wahrscheinlich hier vorne oder so na ja
genau entspannt gut kann ich mich
erstmal einmal die runde wird komplette
scheiße eine pistole habe ich wow das
ist ja toll damit werde ich richtig weit
kommen was haben wir hier ein
maschinengewehr das freut mich doch noch
eine pistole
wow das wird haben mehr ich sehe schon
kommen die runde die werde ich rasiere
noch eine pistole war kommt kann es mir
noch eine gibt okay das entlastet
das sind meine das sind liebte das die
liebe ich solche oder drin ist keine
truhe okay das ist natürlich entspannt
hier drin ist auch nicht das ist ja auch
schön ist auch nichts drin und ein typ
ist hinter mir mit einer waffe das ist
ja wundervoll freunde haben wir hier
wenigstens irgendwas war eine pistole
edu das freut mich dabei und kriegen bei
imo muss nach das ist das ist doch nicht
wahr man dir kommt einer runter
gesprochen und das ist schön hier drauf
gehen
was an der stelle will ich das hier
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren ich finde dass ich mich
ein wenig auf jeden fall und vorteil
verbessert habe wenn ihr noch weitere
tipps habt schreibt gerne die kommentare
wenn ihnen solche challenges sehen
wollte wie beispielsweise herum und
versucht so lange wie möglich zu
überleben ohne waffen oder wenn der
andere ständig ideen habt könnt jetzt
einfach in die kommentare schreiben und
jetzt will ich will eigentlich noch
sagen das war es jetzt hier vom wie hier
können jetzt hier meinen kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
aus checken jetzt findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon nach unten
könnt ihr auch die glocke klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]